PATRICK: Welcome to the Council on Foreign
Relations.
My name is Stewart Patrick.
I'm a senior fellow here at the Council, and
I have the privilege of directing the program
on International Institutions and Global Governance
and of working closely with the members of
the Council of Councils.
I'm here this morning to kick off a very brief
overview of the Report Card on International
Cooperation, which is the second installment
of this annual product that we've launched.
And then we're going to have a discussion
of-with leaders of four members of our think-tank
network, moderated by Marcus Mabry, who is
the managing editor of TwitterMoments.
He'll engage the four members of this network
in a discussion about the findings that we've
had and their implications.
Before we get to the main event, though, I
want to give you just a quick run-through
about the major components and the major findings,
the headlines of this report card.
The Council of Councils was created in 2012,
and it brings together 26 of the world's leading
policy institutes to seek policy solutions
to some of the world's most pressing transnational
problems.
Its composition-that is, of the Council of
Councils-is roughly equivalent to the Group
of 20 in terms of national representation.
And its rationale is similar.
What we try to do is bridge gaps between established
and emerging powers on the requirements for
effective multilateral cooperation in the
21st century.
Now, we're all aware of how urgent this goal
is.
Wherever we look, we see transnational challenges
and problems that defy purely national solutions.
These range from climate change to financial
volatility, nuclear proliferation, to jihadist
terrorism.
One of the most poignant that we saw over
the last 12 months, obviously, is the global
migration crisis and refugee crisis.
Now, this is something that's been going on
in other parts of the world, but it washed
up on Europe's shores last year and suddenly
there was lots of international attention
about it.
But around the world, for the first time,
more than 60 million people are displaced,
either as refugees or as internally displaced
people.
Now, all of these international problems are
occurring at a time of surging geopolitical
rivalry, anemic global growth, state failure
in many parts of the world, and frankly an
angry populism that has affected this country
and many other countries.
Yet despite these challenges and these negative
trends, the 2016 edition of the report card
offers a few glimmers of hope.
In the last year, the world took promising
signs-promising steps to mitigate and adapt
to climate change, most obviously in the Paris
agreements in December of this last year.
It also took steps in nuclear proliferation
in the Joint Comprehensive Plan of Action
to limit Iran's nuclear capability.
And also in September at the U.N. General
Assembly, the world ratified or endorsed the
sustainable development goals, which are designed
to help organize the fight against global
poverty and improve human well-being around
the world through 2030.
Despite these bright spots, there are a number
of weaknesses, however, in terms of our approach
to global governance.
It's clear that international institutions
have not kept pace with fast-changing global-excuse
me-with a fast-paced global context, including
the emergence of new powers and the rise of
new threats.
Since the year 2000, the world has arguably
experienced the fastest and most dramatic
redistribution of world power in modern history.
Established and emerging powers often see
the world in very different ways.
They have different values, and their interests
are often colliding.
We see this geopolitical rivalry from Eastern
Europe to the Far East to the Middle East.
And we've seen that get in the way of handling
some of the most intractable territorial and
other disputes in those regions.
Meanwhile, creaky international organizations,
from the United Nations to the IMF to the
World Health Organization, are having a difficult
time adapting to this new world.
There's been no change in the composition
of the permanent membership of the Security
Council since 1945, and no change in its membership
at all since the early 1960s.
With respect to the International Monetary
Fund, it took five years after a modest agreement
on the-when so-called Chairs and Shares at
the International Monetary Fund was negotiated
in 2010 for finally the U.S. Congress to pass
that legislation almost at the end of this
last year.
And we've seen the World Health Organization
struggle mightily to respond first to Ebola
and now to try to get on top of the Zika virus.
Mitigating the downside of globalization and
taking advantage of its upside requires new
and creative approaches to cooperation amongst
the world's most influential governments.
But that cooperation can only occur if countries
agree on where we are and where we might be
going.
And that's where the report card comes in.
As you can see in this slide, we asked the
heads of the Council of Councils institutions
to assess international cooperation on 10
critical challenges.
They include preventing nuclear proliferation,
managing the global economy, mitigating and
adapting to climate change, advancing development,
promoting global health, expanding global
trade, managing cyber-governance, combating
transnational terrorism, and preventing and
responding to violent conflict, both between
states and within states.
In each case, we asked the think-tank heads
to do three things: First, grade international
cooperation in 2015, both overall and in each
issue area; second, to rank these challenges
on the basis of their importance; and third,
to assess opportunities for breakthrough in
2016.
So what did we find?
Overall, the world made important progress
in the past year, buoyed by some of the positive
developments that I described previously.
The COC awarded an overall-overall efforts
a grade of "B," a full letter-grade improvement
over the previous year.
At the same time, there was significant variation
across issue areas.
In terms of grades, as in last year's edition,
the report card gave the lowest grades to
violent conflict between states to efforts
to resolve issues related to transnational
terrorism and to efforts to resolve or prevent
internal violent conflict.
All of these are obviously intertwined in
the situation in Syria, which, as we all know,
has now entered its sixth year of civil war,
with apparently no end in sight.
Now, with respect to importance, you'll notice
that the lowest performers are also the biggest
areas that the Council identifies as the highest
priorities.
Also the uneven economic recovery prompted
the COC leaders-the uneven global economic
recovery prompted COC leaders to put managing
the global economy right after those-that
cluster of conflict issues in terms of importance,
in terms of what the international community
needs to focus on.
In terms of opportunities for breakthrough,
mitigating and adapting to climate change
registers first here as countries begin to
implement their Paris pledges.
The report card was also optimistic about
advances in global trade, notwithstanding
the complications of trying to get agreement
on the Trans-Pacific Partnership in terms
of its ratification and the Transatlantic
Trade and Investment Partnership, the negotiations
of which continue.
Once again, you'll see that conflict and terrorism
cluster together as representing the poorest
performers in terms of opportunities for breakthrough.
I'm coming to the end of my allotted time,
but I want to point out that both the hard
copy that you all have had distributed to
you and also the interactive Web-based version
contain a number of other compelling features.
Each issue description-that is, each description
of the 10 issue areas-includes several components.
One is a section we call By the Numbers, which
you'll see down below, which has revealing
statistics about that particular issue area.
Then there's more in-depth analysis that has
been written by Council on Foreign Relations
staff that places the grades and rankings
that you see into a broader context, an analytic
context.
We also have a graph that shows how many of
the respondents assigned each grade for each
particular issue area.
And then finally we have comments and policy
prescriptions by each of the heads of the
Council of Councils network.
We also have an interactive map that displays
comments from the heads of the Council of
Council member institutes.
And you can filter these by both country and
issue area.
We encourage you to explore the Report Card
on International Cooperation, both in its
paper and its online form.
We'd love to hear back from you as to what
you think about it, where you think we might
be able to improve its presentation or its
analysis.
And we look forward to your comments as we
try to make this product as useful as possible
in the years ahead.
Before closing, I do want to thank three people
whose work was indispensable in bringing this
product to fruition.
The first is Megan Roberts, who's my associate
director down in Washington.
I'd also like to thank Terry (sp) Mullan,
who is coordinating our work with the Council
of Councils membership, and also Theresa Lou,
who has been assisting us in these-in this
process.
Now it's my great privilege to introduce Marcus
Mabry of Twitter.
Marcus is going to introduce his fellow panelists
and lead them in a discussion on the contemporary
crisis of global governance.
Thank you very much.
(Applause.)
MABRY: Thank you, Stewart, for that introduction
and for that overview of the report.
Let me start off with some announcements.
Welcome to today's Council on Foreign Relations
meeting.
This special event is part of the 2016 Council
of Councils annual conference and is the launch
of the Council of Councils Report Card on
International Cooperation.
I'm going to start off by-we're going to talk
first up here amongst ourselves for about
half an hour, and then we'll toss it out to
the members and to any press to get your questions
asked directly to the Council of Council leaders.
This is obviously an incredibly august body,
both physically here in front of us and intellectually
and visually on the report that's in front
of you and the one that's online; 25 think
tanks on foreign policy, with some of the
greatest minds on our planet, tackling the
issue of global governance at a critical time.
So I think we're all very privileged to be
here this morning.
I'm going to very quickly do some brief introductions,
bios.
You have them in front of you, so I won't
go at great length.
But immediately to my left is Dr. Michael
Fullilove, who is the executive director of
the Lowy Institute for International Policy.
He has been a visiting fellow in foreign policy
at the Brookings Institution and an adviser
to Prime Minister Paul Keating and is the
author of "Rendezvous with Destiny: How Franklin
D. Roosevelt and Five Extraordinary Men Took
America Into the War and Into the World."
Welcome.
FULLILOVE: Thank you, Marcus.
MABRY: Dr. Richard Haass, many of you may
know, is the 13th-in his 13th year as president
of the Council on Foreign Relations, which
is extraordinary for those of us who've been
here this whole time-(laughs)-it happened
fast-and is the author-and is, of course-was
the senior Middle East adviser to President
George H.W.
Bush and was a principal adviser to Secretary
of State Colin Powell under President George
W. Bush and also was a-the U.S. coordinator
for policy toward the future of Afghanistan,
amongst a whole bunch of other roles.
Richard is the author or editor of 12 books
on U.S. foreign policy.
To his left is Professor Sook Jong Lee, who
is the president of the East Asia Institute,
an independent nonprofit think tank based
on Seoul.
She is a professor of public administration
and holds a number of advisory positions in
the South Korean government, including in
the Presidential National Security Advisory
Group, the Presidential Committee for Unification
Preparation, and since 2015 she has served
on the Steering Committee of the World Movement
for Democracy.
Welcome.
Finally, and certainly last but certainly
not least, is General Amos Yadlin, who has
been the director of Tel Aviv University's
Institute for National Security Studies, Israel's
leading strategic think tank, since November
2011.
He served for over 40 years in the Israeli
Defense Forces, nine of which he served as
a member of the IDF General Staff.
Amongst many other appointments, he has been
the IDF's chief of defense intelligence.
He has accumulated about 5,000 flight hours
and a few more than 25-more than 250 combat
missions, including during the Yom Kippur
War and Operation Tammuz, which destroyed
the Osirak nuclear reactor in Iraq.
As I said, a very distinguished body.
Thank you all.
Please welcome them all for me.
(Applause.)
Now, since the meat of our body before us-obviously,
as a journalist, it is-we're usually a cynical
body, and so you might be-I might be forgiven
if I were to say, given the state of the world
and the general pessimism that many of us
feel about it-(chuckles)-and pessimism is
not a light word; despair, great fear, and
dread-a "B" is a really surprising grade from
your report.
So I'm going to start-I'll ask Richard this
question, out of fairness to our guests: Is
this a subject of grade inflation, or how
did we get this "B"?
(Laughter.)
HAASS: The conclusion I've reached is that
a lot of my colleagues are aiming to become
professors at Harvard.
(Laughter.)
They have understood the culture there, where
it's very hard to get below a "B."
So I think this is a glass-half-full sort
of take on the world.
It's taking certain developments at, if you
will, face value and putting the best possible
face on them, saying what was accomplished
is a good baseline and it will lead to better
things in the future.
I think that's the way that-at the risk of
speaking for my two dozen colleagues-one would
interpret something like the Paris accord
on climate change, the Iran agreement, what
was achieved with the Development Goals, and
trade with TPP.
So all of these things were achievements on
the surface, in the sense that they got done.
Where I think the glass is half-empty in every
case is that, also referring to Harvard, we
used to teach at the Kennedy School that 90
percent of life was implementation, and this
leaves the 90 percent.
So there's the real question about, in each
one of those things: Will the Development
Goals become reality?
Will TPP and other trade agreements ever come
into effect?
In the case of climate, which I'm quite skeptical
about, you had aspirational goals at the national
level.
The collective goal, what the effect would
be on temperature, even if implemented would
fall way short of what the declared aims would
be.
But again, a lot of the goals were simply
aspirational.
The Iran agreement, I expect Amos and others
will talk about it in great detail, but I
would-I would simply say that it left unanswered
at least as many problems as it purported
to address.
So I actually think the grade is quite generous,
even overly-even overly generous.
But I would simply, you know, put that out
there, if you will, as a-as a starting point.
MABRY: Excellent.
Thank you for that context.
Professor Lee, one of the areas in which-a
region which we have not seen, perhaps with
the exception perhaps of the TPP, real progress
toward this governance, even the jaw-someone
might call it the jawboning progress of the
agreements, inasmuch as they were agreements,
is your part of the world.
So in a world of increasing tension, certainly
in the South China Sea-certainly one of the
areas in which the report was, indeed, pessimistic
was proliferation issues, North Korea's nuclear
capabilities-what are the steps that could
be taken, as far as international governance,
to put us in a better position in those issues-those
regional issues in Asia?
LEE: Marcus, as you have mentioned, we have
very challenging issues, especially in East
Asia.
We don't have a Pan-Asia governance system
to respond to these territorial issues.
So, therefore, and especially in South China
Sea, you know, China has drawn unilaterally
nine-dash line, and then there is a lot of
disputes with-especially with the Philippines
in Spratly Islands and Vietnam in the Paracel
Island(s).
As you know, the Philippines brought a case
to the Permanent Court of Arbitration, and
is under the UNCLOS, the U.N. Convention on
Law of the Sea.
So the court is looking at the case.
And as far as I know, by the end of July their
conclusion will be drawn among-from the five
judges.
So that would be a great blow to China.
China, of course, don't respect or don't believe
the international maritime law, even though
they are a member of UNCLOS.
And they believe this maritime governance
was kind of dominated by the Western interests,
and they like to come up with the alternative
norms to deal with these complex issues.
And NPT-wise, of course, despite the successful
deal between USA and Iran, if you look at
North Korea, it's a terrible situation.
And North Korean tested nuclear weapons 2006,
2009, and 2013, and January this year.
So they detonated four times.
And as you know, the U.N. Security Council
responded to this force claiming to be hydrogen
detonations with a strong Resolution 2270,
covering the cargo inspections and the banning
inflow of airplane fuel, and also banning
the trading the minerals such as gold and
titanium.
So this time it's lucky that China is more
willing to cooperate with this resolution.
However, there are many loopholes, you know.
For example, it was (lively for the purpose
?), you know, that North Korea can export
coal through Dandong city.
So we'll see.
Because this resolution was drawn in March
2nd, I think the kind of monitoring report
will come in June, as far as I know.
MABRY: Do you think there's a chance that
any of these international-this international
intervention, in terms of norms and laws and
constrictions, will stop North Korea?
It hasn't yet.
Will it stop North Korea's nuclear program?
LEE: It's very difficult because there is
no good options, you know.
And this young leader, Kim Jong-un, who tested
twice after he succeeded his father, defy
this international law and governance.
And in recent Workers Party Congress two weeks
ago, he declared that North Korea is a nuclear
state.
So I don't think he's going to give it up.
But, you know, this time it is a very strong
resolution, so we have to-the international
society-have to work together to exercise
diplomatic pressure and in sharing information.
But there is a kind of-it's very difficult
to coordinate sanctions among the major stakeholders-USA
and China and Japan and South Korea.
MABRY: And that continues to be a weakness
of international governance, in fact.
LEE: Yes.
MABRY: General, obviously, in your neighborhood,
we have the kind of-again, what even the report
acknowledges is the most despairing situation
on the planet right now with regard to conflict,
both internally displaced and trans-border
conflict.
Do you see any international governance hope?
Because, again, it seems we've failed massively
with regards to Syria, and even in some degree
with regards to ISIS.
Do you see any hope for international governance
having any successes in that realm?
Or is all lost, and must we appeal to something
other than transnational institutions?
YADLIN: Yeah, I want to first refer to the
report optimism, because there are a saying
that a pessimist is an optimist with experience.
(Laughter.)
So you see that the head of the think tanks
are quite optimist even though they are very
experienced, or they gave the job to their
young research assistant.
(Laughter.)
Albert Einstein was asked by one of his students
about the coming examination.
And the student asked, are the questions going
to be the same like last year?
And Einstein replied that the question will
be the same question, but the answer is going
to be different this year.
(Laughter.)
Which means the world is changing, and changing
fast.
And if you take my region, there are like
five states that, when we went to high school,
they were states-Iraq, Syria, Libya, Yemen,
Lebanon-not anymore.
There are new states that we never recognized,
but they are there on the ground: Kurdistan,
Hamas-stan, the Islamic State.
So it's a different world.
And sometimes we are judging it with rules
and norms and international governance that
belong to a different period.
I think the grade here is reflecting a very
short-range looking at the world.
And maybe for 2016 it's the right view, but
my concern is for the long run.
And I think think tanks should look at the
long run.
And there is a methodology issue here, that
the most important problems are on the lowest
grade.
So somebody has to do the balance and to give
it some-in the final grade, how come the most
important issue get the lowest grade, and
they are the most difficult to deal with?
This is very important finding of the report
and need to change the final score.
So, on proliferation, I think Iran is a wonderful
example, because my grade to the Iranian deal
was not "F" like my prime minister, which
says this is a new Holocaust.
It is not a new Holocaust because Israel is
very strong and Israel can cope even with
nuclear Iran, even though nuclear Iran is
a very, very grave and bleak development.
It is not a diplomatic achievement that will
bring another Nobel Prize.
No, it's in the middle.
In the short run, it's "B." It's "B" because
Iran is rolled back a year.
And if-and this is a big "if"-if they will
keep the agreement, they will stay there for
10, 12, 15 years.
Depends on what area of the-of the agreement.
However, it is not "A-minus."
"A-minus" was three years.
"A" was, you know, no nuclear capabilities
in Iran.
So still very close to the bomb upon this
issue.
But the "F" is in the long run.
The "F" is in the long run, because in the
long run this agreement gave Iran a legitimacy
to have an unlimited nuclear program with
200,000 centrifuges if they wish, 30 nuclear
reactor(s) if they wish.
MABRY: How do you define the long run?
What-
YADLIN: Ten to 15 years.
This is the agreement.
HAASS: When the ceilings expire.
YADLIN: And if we are at that time with the
same regime that called to the elimination
of my country, this is a big problem for the
world security and safety.
And then you take North Korea, that basically
signed the same agreement in the '90s and
violated after a couple of years.
So I think the main challenge for us is not
to argue about how good is the deal, it's
to look into the future 10 years.
And here are very shortly three scenarios.
One, optimistic: the Iranians are changing,
the young generation, the Facebook generation,
the Twitter generation-
MABRY: Thank you.
(Laughter.)
YADLIN: -is coming forward and taking over
from the mullahs.
OK, this is an optimistic scenario: the Iranians
become Norwegians, wonderful.
(Laughter.)
Percentage, Richard?
HAASS: Approximately 5 percent.
YADLIN: Five percent.
Amazing, my number as well.
(Laughter.)
Even though many Americans say, "General,
0.5 (percent)."
But, second, North Korean scenario.
After three years, four years, they got all
the money, they built a better military, and
they violate the agreement.
So North Korea scenario.
And there is even more dangerous one, which
is the Iranian scenario: strategic patience,
and within 10 to 15 years-and this is not
General Yadlin; this is President Obama saying-zero
distance from the bomb.
So it couldn't be an "A-minus."
MABRY: On that question, and I have to ask
you as such an informed source, is it not
inevitable, though, that Iran will be a nuclear
state?
And therefore, is not the "F" inevitable?
YADLIN: It is-it is possible to stop them,
as some other countries were stopped.
Iraq, you mentioned the case.
According to the international media, Syria
2007.
Think about Syria today.
Al Kibar, where the nuclear- the North Korean
nuclear reactor, which has only one use, for
military war, is in the hands of-this is a
territory now occupied by ISIS.
Think about it.
And ISIS hasn't attacked Israel.
London, Brussels, Turkey, Syria, Iraq.
So I think Iran should not have a nuclear
program.
And they can be stopped if the countries that-by
the way, this is the only point that President
Obama and Prime Minister Netanyahu agrees-only
point-which say that Iran will not have the
nuclear bomb.
So let's hope that the two gentlemen will,
in case of the two bleak scenarios, not the
optimistic one, will do what they have to
do in the next-if Iran will violate the agreement.
HAASS: Marcus, if I could say one thing, it
wasn't inevitable that North Korea reach this
point.
The United States and others made decisions
in the early 1990s not to act when there were
military options to do it.
Now we've got to live with the consequences.
And there are still options if the United
States and others want to put them on the
table to force North Korea out of the nuclear
business, particularly if China will cooperate.
MABRY: Military options, you're talking about.
HAASS: Or even short of military options,
if China will cooperate.
If China were to ramp up sanctions against
North Korea, I don't think the country could
survive for more than a matter of weeks.
So there are options against North Korea.
There are options against Iran.
There were historically options against others.
Nuclear proliferation is not inevitable.
What it is is, yes, you've got countries that
are determined to go down that path, but the
United States and other countries have made
political calculations, weighing their opposition
to nonproliferation against other interests.
And we have often been prepared to essentially
life with certain outcomes because we had
competing interests-whether it was cooperating
with Pakistan in certain contexts or what
have you.
So there's very little that's inevitable.
Most of what happens is the result of a conscious
or in some cases unconscious choices.
MABRY: And as you know better than probably
anyone in the room, the calculation there,
the means interest calculation-the interest
calculation-the competing interest calculations,
are sometimes political and sometimes economic.
Sometimes it's a loss of life that is not
considered to be politically viable.
HAASS: These are tough choices.
I don't mean to sit here and be glib.
And in the early 1990s, for example, the United
States, when North Korea's nuclear program
consisted of rods and cooling ponds, before
they moved them there was a major debate in
the Clinton administration and beyond whether
that was the moment to attack North Korea.
Now, it could have been done and we could
have stopped their nuclear program.
North Korea could have retaliated in many
ways.
There probably would have been a war on the
peninsula.
It would have been extreme consequential for
South Korea, for Japan and the United States
given our treaty-
MABRY: How many losses in South Korea?
HAASS: Pardon me?
MABRY: How many losses-
HAASS: Well, we don't know.
Again, you can play-we can't say for certain
how it would have played out militarily, how
long it would have gone on, and so forth.
But obviously given where Seoul is, given
North Korea's conventional military might,
you have to assume it would have been consequential.
So I'm not saying that the-I'm not saying
the alternatives were cheap or easy.
Again, I'm not being glib.
I'm simply saying that choices not to act
against proliferation, for legitimate reasons,
had tremendous consequences.
And we're living with them today.
And quite honestly, I would think one of the
next great foreign policy crises, that is
quite possible the next occupant of the Oval
Office will face, is what to do if and when
the director of national intelligence waltzes
into the Oval Office one morning and says:
North Korea can now put a number of small
nuclear warheads on missiles that can reach
California.
Are we prepared to tolerate this?
If not, what are you prepared to do, Mr. President?
Here is a set of really unattractive options.
And that day is likely to come about somewhere
within the next five years.
LEE: Marcus, can I add?
MABRY: Yes.
LEE: You know, President Obama has been taking
strategic patience to North Korea with the
availability of missile and lightening the
nuclear warhead.
And now there's serious worry about North
Korea's nuclear threat, right?
So I think that they will engage.
However, whatever mode of engagement will
be-and it's very offensive for South Korea
to calculate how many South Koreans can die
if they take military options.
So I would strongly oppose any military strike
because in the Korean south is too close to
Pyongyang.
So any damages are, you know, sacrificing
our own citizens is not negotiable.
MABRY: It's excellent to have the very hard
choices to talk about here on the stage this
morning.
Dr. Fullilove, thank you for your patience,
and I turn to you for-
FULLILOVE: Strategic patience.
(Laughter.)
MABRY: Exactly.
Exactly.
I do like that strategic patience thing from
now on.
I'm going to use that, with regards to my
six-year old twins, because I have no strategic
patience.
I'm going to have to develop some.
Dr. Fullilove, in this context right now,
we've heard about national interest.
And we've been talking for a few minutes,
you know, competing national interests among
the closest allies.
In this world, what hope is there-I turn that
same question-for transnational, international
governance?
I mean, on a bilateral situation we can't
agree.
So internally the states are falling apart
that barely ever existed and new states are
coming into being which are not recognized
as states, or as actors even.
What hope is there for any of this governance
issue?
FULLILOVE: Well, let me make a few introductory
comments, if I can.
First of all, can I thank Richard and his
colleagues at CFR for hosting us at the Council
of Councils.
And can I commend Richard for his vision in
establishing the Council of Councils.
I know it sounds a bit like the Illuminati-(laughter)-or
I'm always reminded of-you remember the commission
in the Godfather movies, where the heads of
the different families come together to solve
their problems?
HAASS: You really have to go down this path?
(Laughter.)
MABRY: What does that make Richard?
Who does that make Richard?
HAASS: My Twitter feed now will-(laughter)-
FULLILOVE: I'm trying to help Marcus with
company.
(Laughter.)
MABRY: And we appreciate it.
FULLILOVE: Yeah.
No, but seriously, I think the Council of
Councils is a very powerful organization with
a great deal of potential.
And I find it incredibly valuable to get together
every year with my counterparts.
And I want to thank the Stewart in particular,
and his team, for putting together this report
card.
And I think we've had a great conversation.
Everybody's going to disagree with the report
card in some way, and I'm going to pile on.
But it's getting us talking about what the
issues are.
I'm a historian by training.
And so why these grades seem odd to me is
that, as Amos says, when you look at the long
view you end up much more pessimistic about
it.
You remember when Dean Acheson wrote his memoir
of his time as President Truman's secretary
of state, he called it present at the creation.
And indeed, Acheson's generation did create
the post-war world.
They rescued Europe from financial ruin.
They created the institutions that we're talking
about.
But now, 70 years later, Acheson's creation
is beset on all sides.
The liberal international order is less liberal,
less international, less orderly.
The United States is inching back from the
world, or has inched back in the last few
years.
Other challenges are inching forward, which
are making resolution to some of these questions
like North Korea more difficult.
The Middle East, as Amos said, is-the old
state system is a state of collapse.
The planet is heating up.
There are more refugees-we haven't touched
on this-there are more refugees and asylum
seekers than at any time since the end of
the Second World War.
So it feels to me more like we are present
at the destruction of an order that was created
at the Second World War, and one that has
been remarkably congenial to the interests
of the countries represented on the stage.
So I think it's a bracing moment.
How do you square that historical perspective
with the grades, apart from the fact that
my colleagues on the Council of Council are
optimists?
I think in a couple of ways.
One is that these grades I think are a reflection
of current performance, in a way, relative
to last year's performance.
I think there's also a sense, as Amos says,
that the rankings are as important as the
grades.
It's striking to me that these three conflict
issues are ranked by everybody as the top
global challenges, the bottom of current performance,
and the bottom of the rankings in terms of
opportunities in the future.
But you asked me about where-what we can do
differently and what is the hope for global
governance.
Well, it's an impolite thing to say at a conference
on global governance, but to me the role of
the United States and the U.S. allies is much
more important in preserving international
order than the United Nations or other institutions.
That's not to say those institutions aren't
important.
They are.
But in terms of the underlying power dynamics
of how the world works, I think these big
nations led by the United States is the most
important issue.
And so to me, what can we all do?
Well, we would like to see a United States
that is engaged in the world, that steps back
into the world, that leads.
I would like to see a Western bloc that picks
up, that recovers its mojo in a way, that
focuses on its external obligations, as well
as its internal debacles.
You know, I sometimes feel at the moment that
we in the West are a bit like the priest and
the Levite in the parable of the good Samaritan.
We come across something unpleasant-an unpleasant
scene, like a neighbor being set upon by an
aggressor, as in the case of Crimea, and we
prefer to pass by on the other side.
And that's last year's news.
We're not talking about Crimea anymore, even
though when Russia invaded Crimea it breached
the central tenet of the state system on which
our international system has been based for
70 years.
So I'm an Australian, therefore I'm more on
the pessimistic side naturally than the optimistic
side.
I'm an historian, so I'm a bit concerned about
where we are.
But in terms of a positive vision, it's not
so much, I don't think, about tinkering with
institutions, although that's important.
It's about first of all the United States
and how it sees its role in the world, and
secondly how those of us who are allied with
the United States and friendly with the United
States, and like-minded, how we feel we can
contribute to solving some of these awful,
bloody challenges.
MABRY: Well, that being the case, and given
your own role and history as a scholar of
the United States, a student of the United
States' history and its politics, do you have
any cause for optimism, given what's happening
in the United States?
(Laughter.)
FULLILOVE: Look-(laughter)-look, I would say
this, that there is obviously a circus atmosphere
in your politics at the moment.
Like kind of a Coney Island sort of feel.
And I'll be honest, there's something to that
in my own country's politics at the moment.
And it's one of the things we were discussing
at breakfast that sort of underline the drooping
confidence in the West is that in so many
of our countries there is a disaffection with
elites, there is a growing populism, there's
a lack of-there's a lack of patience in the
public.
I mean, in my own country, for example, we
had 25 years where there were only two governments.
So in other words, governments could consistently
articulate a vision, win reelection, and then
prosecute those changes.
And so we had three prime ministers in 25
years.
And in the last six or seven years, we've
had five prime ministers.
We're the Italy of the Pacific.
Actually, Italy is much more stable now than
we are.
(Laughter.)
So I'm not really in a position to lecture
you about your politics.
But I guess to me, it's-I mean, we can criticize
individual politicians, like Mr. Trump.
But I think actually we need to look at ourselves
as publics and say: When did we lose the patience?
When did we lose the ability to make long-term
decisions, to see the long term, not to judge
in terms of our-not to give way to our own
prejudices and our own instincts, but to sort
of apply some critical reason to it?
I think Australians need to do that.
And I'd respectfully submit that if Americans
do that, then I think there is some room for
optimism, because I think the general perception
is that although President Obama has been
a terrific president and the right president
to come after President Bush, that perhaps
America has overlearned the lessons of the
Iraq War, and inched back a little bit more
from the world than it should have.
And it's time for the United States to step
back in.
So fingers crossed.
MABRY: Do you want to?
HAASS: Two reactions.
One on the U.S.
I thought the most interesting thing in the
last few months was the Pew poll that came
out recently.
And what it essentially said is that a majority
of Americans think that we're spending too
much, as a country, of our resources and attention
on the world and much more concern with things
going on here.
I think the obvious frustration with that
is they don't see the connection between what's
going on out there and what's going on here.
But I actually think it is reflective of where
the country is.
There is a pushback against what are the perceived
effects of globalization, against trade.
There's still the intervention fatigue after
Iraq and Afghanistan.
So I think it goes far beyond any personality
or candidate.
I actually think this is something of the
zeitgeist of the country, and I think it's
a reality that any person who, you know, comes
into office this, you know, and takes the
oath of office in January is going to have
to-going to have to contend with.
So I think Michael's going to be a little
bit disappointed if he expects to see a tremendous
revival.
There may be some inching back, and I think
that's probably likely.
But I don't think you're going to see anything
fundamental.
Secondly, I think, in terms of the world-and
it's implicit in what I think you've heard
up here-is-I think the quickest way I could
summarize it is that there's few phrases in
our business that are invoked more often than
"international community."
And I think part of the underlying reality
is there is very little international community.
There isn't the consensus about what ought
to be the rules.
There isn't a willingness to act on their
behalf.
So the phrase is invoked as though it were
a reality.
And while there's elements of it in certain
areas, and we see it in the report-there might
be elements of it in the economic, or elements
of it particularly in principle in certain
areas-what there are are very few elements
of it in practice.
And indeed, in some cases there's downright
opponents of it.
So you can't speak of an international community
in the Middle East when you have countries
like Iran or various groups pursuing their
goals.
Or you can't speak of an international community
when it comes to the Asia-Pacific, given some
of the behaviors, obviously of North Korea
but also, say, China, or what Russia's doing
in Europe, or in cyberspace.
There isn't a community of thought about what
the role of governments ought to be in setting
the norms, much less what the norms ought
to be.
So I think that this report is taking place
in a-in a context in which the realities are
in many cases far, far south of what the hopes
are.
And I think, again, that's what we're capturing
in the report.
The report is upbeat.
I think the reality is considerably less rosy
than that.
MABRY: Oftentimes in the American polity we
talk about this as a challenge of leadership,
and if the right leader came along, they could
make it all change.
Is that reasonable?
HAASS: I think that's exaggerated.
If I could ban certain things in writing,
one would be the last paragraph of virtually
half the articles and books I read: "but if
there's the adequate amount of political will
and leadership, all will be solved."
Well, look, leadership also depends upon context.
It depends on followership.
So leadership can basically point in certain
directions.
But again, leaders can't choose their inbox.
They can't choose their context.
They can shape it.
They can have a difference on it.
You know, human agency can matter.
But it's not simply about leaders.
I think that's-and that's true within the
United States, and it's true within the world
given the role of the United States.
It's more than simply of some abstract measure
of leadership, as though that were that you-if
you only had the leadership, solutions would
follow.
If only it were so.
MABRY: At this time, I would like to invite
members to join our conversation with their
questions.
A reminder that this meeting is on the record,
and please wait for the microphone.
Speak directly into it.
Please stand.
State you name and affiliation.
And please limit yourself to one question,
and keep it concise to allow as many members
as possible to speak.
OK, so right here in the first table.
Right here.
Here ma'am, here's the mic.
Q: Nan Keohane, Princeton University.
I was thinking about your grading system,
and I wanted to ask a question about the conditions
for grade improvement.
In climate change, you have a move from a
"C-plus" to an "A" in one year.
As a professor, I regard that as amazing.
And I wanted to ask you all, whoever would
like to answer, whether there are any lessons
to be learned from the climate-change area
for other problems that we face?
I know it's mostly Paris.
We can argue about how effective Paris is
or was, but it's clearly significant for bringing
people together.
What can we learn from Paris?
MABRY: Are there lessons from the other areas?
Richard?
HAASS: I think there is a big lesson.
The reason you had some-at least the appearance,
and perhaps the reality of progress of Paris
this year was in no small part because Paris
represented a fundamental departure from previous
efforts to come up with a global agreement
on climate change.
So, gone was the idea of a top-down market,
you know, approach-so, cap and trade, where
everyone was assigned market shares with some
kind of a trading system.
Gone was the idea of creating a carbon tax.
It may make the most sense in purely economic
assessments, but it simply can't be negotiated.
So, what did Paris do?
Paris was actually a big idea.
I was skeptical a few minutes ago, but I do
think there's a nugget of a really big and
intriguing idea in Paris.
What you basically did was had countries show
up and say, here's our expression of our commitment,
what we used to call in the foreign aid business
"best efforts."
Here's what we're going to commit to doing.
It's not legally binding, but we're, in many
cases, going to state it: by so and so date,
we're going to try to peak our output at this
amount.
Some countries would simply say, like China,
by 2030, we're going to peak; we're not going
to tell you what it is.
India wouldn't even go that far.
But many countries did say, here's what we
aim to do.
This, to me, is potentially a new form of
multilateralism.
Rather than having binding, legal, top-down
agreements, what you have are essentially
coordination of national policies.
I can imagine it in the health realm.
I can imagine it dealing with-we're already
seeing it-in some ways the Financial Stability
Board is an example of it in the monetary
and banking regulation realm.
So it's a less-binding, less-classic form
of multilateralism.
But what it-where it might make the most sense-and
I think you're onto something, Nan-is in those
areas of behavior which are fundamentally
domestic, but which have international consequences,
I think the Paris approach represents an intellectual
breakthrough.
And I think it's not as ambitious, but it's
a far more doable and realistic approach to
building international support.
You don't require consensus.
What you require is domestic best efforts,
and then it becomes additive.
So, I actually think Paris is an intriguing
way in certain areas of, you know, that's
being looked at in this report card to go
about the business of making progress on specific
issues.
MABRY: Excellent.
Yes, right here.
Sir.
Q: Ettore Greco, Institute International Affairs
in Italy.
The report gives a relatively optimistic grade
on the efforts to expand free trade.
But we are now witnessing a mounting resistance
and opposition, both in U.S. and Europe.
Perhaps the grade given by the report reflects
the successful negotiations on the TPP.
But now, for instance, in the U.S., both presumptive
nominees are campaigning against the transatlantic
pact, the transatlantic treaty.
So, could you please comment?
Perhaps this is the type of difference between
shortsighted and longsighted view?
I don't know.
So could you please comment on this problem?
MABRY: So, who'd like to handle that?
Because you also talk about the TTIP as well
and its possibility of coming or not.
Professor Lee, would you like to?
LEE: Yeah, OK.
If I talk about Asia-Pacific region, you know,
there is a very interesting movement.
This is because different mode of regional
economic trade organizations or the cooperations.
Of example, the ASEAN-led 16 countries RCEP,
I think in September they're going to end
up the 14 rounds of negotiations.
And then we have also TTP, with 12 signatories,
and-
MABRY: And South Korea not a part.
LEE: South Korea like to enter the second
round.
But with this difficulty of the ratification
in Washington, we'll see.
(Chuckles.)
MABRY: (Laughs.)
LEE: And at the same time, you know, there
is interesting AIIB, the Asia Investment Infrastructure
Bank, initiated by China.
So in Asia, we thought there is a coming of
a kind of competition between China-led economic
and trade or even investment organization
versus U.S.-led TPP.
But I see this is not a good idea if the economic,
you know, cooperations should be work together.
So, I think it's more rational for USA to
be a member of AIIB rather than just to, you
know, vetoing AIIB.
So, by participating in AIIB, you know, we
can make the governments more democratic and
transparent rather than by (conflict ?).
HAASS: I'll talk about trade.
Just on trade very quickly, world trade has
not been growing for about the last five years-very
little.
And, you know, more than anything it's because
economies aren't growing.
But also, it's now been, what-I lost count
of the years, but since, what, 15 years ago,
the Doha Development Round.
Global trade talks are going nowhere.
It's not clear they can revive given, you
know, any time you try to get agreement with
190 countries, good luck.
And that's the old-fashioned legally binding
approach, very, very tough.
So what we're seeing is the proliferation
of regional, and bilateral, and various types
of multilateral trade agreements, which are
at best second best.
There's people like Jagdish Bhagwati who think
they're actually quite, on balance, bad.
But I would simply say I think they're second
best in what issues they can handle, and I
think it comes up against now also the domestic
pushback.
So I think it-I think it has been a rough
time for trade.
And I think more than anything it's-at the
global level you can't get it negotiated,
and at the domestic level it's not clear you
have the support.
FULLILOVE: Can I just add one-
MABRY: Sure.
FULLILOVE: Can I just pick up something Professor
Lee said about the Asian Investment Infrastructure
Bank?
Because one issue we haven't-we haven't talked
too much about China so far, and everybody
in this room knows that one of the features
of international relations is that sometimes
established and rising powers collide.
And this relationship between China and the
United States is going to be very important
to many of the global governance challenges
that we talk about in the report, not just
the ones in Asia but globally.
And it seems to me that the United States
and like-minded countries need to get the
right balance of engaging and hedging with
China, and sometimes we get that balance quite
wrong.
For example, on the AIIB, I didn't understand
why the United States was so negative about
the-about that particular initiative.
Because if we're not going to allow China
the ability to set up some kind of infrastructure
investment bank in Asia, where it's required,
then what prerogatives are we going to allow
China?
On the other hand, I would be-so I think,
in a way, we were-I think the United States
was hedging too much in relation to China.
But then on other issues-and we've mentioned
the South China Sea-I would say that President
Obama has been too soft.
I would say he's been too down the engagement
end.
So this is going to be, this relationship-these
are just examples of this, but this relationship
between the United States and China is going
to be so important.
Can the two countries come up-arrive at an
order, a new-a new modus operandi where each
of them can achieve their objectives, but
allow the other side to exercise its prerogatives
and allow everybody else in Asia to also exercise
their prerogatives?
Can they get that balance right?
And the importance of statecraft, and leadership,
and getting the right mix of engaging and
hedging, and choosing where to engage and
where to hedge is so hard, which does come
back to leadership.
MABRY: Mmm hmm.
Excellent.
At the very back there.
Q: Thank you.
Hi, my name is Venk Lal.
I'm with EverKey Global.
We're part of Wells Fargo Asset Management.
Thank you very much for all the observations
thus far.
My question relates to some of the recent
commentary you've all been making about trade
and coordination.
If we step back even farther and look at broader
capital flows around the world, and we look
at all the volatility-particularly in currency
markets which really demonstrate, some would
argue, diverging economic interests between
different parts of the world-how does the
Council view prospects for coordination, whether
it's in the reform of Bretton Woods, as there
was some mention of in this report, or other
policies that could very well take place?
Or, alternatively, is it just a matter of
two or three or four central banks at a time
coordinating policy and sort of running away
with the show?
MABRY: Thank you.
Want to take that?
HAASS: Well, I don't think you're going to
get, you know, formal or collective reform
of the Bretton Woods institutions, particularly
the IMF, which would be the most relevant
one.
I think in some ways-I think it was Tim Geithner
who called the rise of the FSB-the Financial
Stability Board-sort of the fourth pillar
now joining the original three.
And when-I think if you look at informal central
bank consultations, you look at essentially
the de facto norms and rules which argue against
certain types of government or central bank
intervention, there's been a bit of progress.
I think there's tension between what you need
to do domestically and its consequences internationally.
That's true for everybody; it's particularly
true for us, since we happen to operating,
the last time I checked, the reserve currency.
So we do quantitative easing and we set rates
based upon domestic projections.
Obviously, though, they have tremendous consequences
for the role of the dollar internationally.
And there's a-there is a tension there.
I'm not sure you can solve it though institutional
fixes, but it seems to me one of the things
that we've got to be sensitive to the consequences,
and you have to have all sorts of formal and
informal conversations.
And increasingly, those are taking place.
I think one of them, I mean, Dan Drezner and
others have written about it, but if you look
at how the world has evolved, say, since 2008-2009,
I think there's been probably more progress.
If I were going to grade-put this on the report
card, there's arguably been as much actual
progress in dealing with the issues you're
raising-the monetary arrangements, banking,
questions of domestic regulatory reform, increasing-reducing
the gaps between countries and increasing
the de facto or informal coordination-I would
think there's probably been as much progress
there as there been in any other-any other
area of, quote unquote, "global governance,"
which is not to say it's perfect, but I do
think there's been some meaningful progress.
MABRY: Professor Lee?
LEE: Can I add?
Because there is a regional effort, as you
remember, for the 1997-1998 Asian financial
crisis.
Many Asian member countries think they need
a kind of regional cooperations in addition
to IMF.
So at the time, you know, Japan initiated
Asian Monetary Fund, but it was opposed by
Washington.
So ever since then, at least with the Chiang
Mai Initiative, at least we set up the kind
of currency swap mechanism.
Now-used to be a bilateral, but now multilateral-like.
So, there is a kind of currency swapping.
You know, when you have a liquidity problem,
we can lend each other.
So, that's kind of progress to-from the region
to reinforce some weakness that the global
organizations such as IMF cannot provide,
and at the right time.
MABRY: OK.
We're going to go right here, and then we'll
go back there.
Q: Rita Hauser.
I find it a little depressing or shocking
that, in your list of items, you have not
listed the grave humanitarian problems that
are facing the world for last two years: migration,
displacement being among them, but massive
violations of human rights, all of which the
entire world community is dedicated to dealing
with and working on a global basis.
We tend to talk about the refugee crisis,
oh, it's in Syria and Iraq, but it's all over.
It's in Asia, it's in Latin America, it's
in Australia, it's everywhere.
Why wasn't it listed, Patrick?
And what do you guys think about it?
(Laughter.)
MABRY: So, we'll go-are you game?
MR.
: Let's go to Patrick.
It's OK.
HAASS: Stewart, you're-
PATRICK: That's a very good question, Rita.
We did incorporate it as a spillover consequence
of violent conflict and both interstate, obviously.
Although people don't pay attention too much
to the displacement in Ukraine, there's been
over a million and a half people in Ukraine
that have been displaced.
And obviously most of the folks, although
not all of the folks fleeing into Europe and
elsewhere, or in the 500,000 in the Dadaab
refugee camp in Kenya, the world's largest
refugee camp, are obviously victims from displacement
of violent conflict in Somalia, primarily.
Arguably, it should be added as another category.
And the-one of the difficulties, of course,
is that there's-there are different categories
of international threats and problems.
And parsing between refugees and migrants,
those are both two issues that conceivably
we could add to this.
But they increasingly overlap, and it's actually
one of the things that we discussed in one
of the sessions at our workshop yesterday.
HAASS: I also think, Rita, in defense of what
we did, you can deal with refugees and people
on the move either within or across borders
as an issue in and of itself, or you can deal
with it mainly as a consequence of bad governance
and internal conflict or interstate conflict.
And this report largely deals with it in the
latter.
So there's not going to be a solution, ultimately,
to problems of displacement or refugees through
some kind of a global legal mechanism dealing
with it.
What we've got to do is deal with the root
causes that's generating the situations where
these people are forced to flee from their
homes.
So I think the emphasis in this report is
more on what's leading to it, rather than
the results of it.
MABRY: Of course, there are international
institutions and legal institutions.
There is transnational government supposedly
around human rights.
HAASS: It's got to be-no-
Q: Yes, there are legal institutions.
HAASS: I understand that, but all I'm saying
is the principal driver of this is-and the
way to resolve it is not going to be whatever
comes out of the U.N. this year dealing with
refugees.
And "global governance," quote/unquote, is
not going to resolve it if we don't do something
on the ground in places like Syria, in parts
of Africa, in the Ukraine.
MABRY: OK.
Yes?
Q: Hi.
Can you hear me?
Giacomo Landi with DNB Bank.
I think we got a good idea of the Israeli-Iranian
situation over the next 12, 15 years, and
maybe some hard lines that Israel has.
I was struck by the response on North Korea,
and I can appreciate the geography of Seoul.
But where does South Korea see the North-South
situation developing over the next 10, 15
years?
Obviously, extremely harsh rhetoric from the
North directed toward the United States.
At some point, we may need to act.
But is there a situation where the South actually
would take the lead on this?
LEE: Actually, any president of South Korean
government has tried to persuade Pyongyang
to improve the inter-Korean relations, like
opening up the Kaesong Industrial Complex,
and then also Kumgang Mountain, many things,
and also tried to set up some economic cooperations.
But, you know, Pyongyang has responded with
a continuous nuclear threat.
It was very difficult, for example, the current
government tried to prepare in a unification
is whole packages of investment, infrastructure,
and trade, and port development, but they
all stopped after the fourth nuclear test
in this January.
So even Kaesong Industrial Complex was shut
down.
Too bad, right?
So, it's very difficult for Seoul to take
in the driver's seat because if Pyongyang
ignore Seoul, and they like to talk with Washington
to get Washington's attention to normalize
the relations, they hope.
Of course, but Washington will need to - the
Pyongyang's sincere attitude of engagement
to dismantle the nuclear programs.
HAASS: I'll just say what worries me-and I
think your question gets at it-is there is
potentially a significant tension, or gap,
between how Seoul and Washington view North
Korea.
If Seoul's priority is at virtually any cost
to avoid another war on the peninsula, which
is understandable; and if Washington is increasingly
concerned about, among other things, North
Korea's nuclear reach, whether it goes on
the market or has missiles that can reach
the United States; you can imagine where suddenly
the coordination of this alliance becomes
extraordinarily difficult.
And I think that's quite a possibility over
the next decade, as North Korean nuclear capabilities
grow.
At the same time, their conventional capabilities
are also considerable.
I think they're-the Washington-Seoul bifurcation,
potentially, is a-is a real challenge.
MABRY: General Yadlin, if I can ask you a
question with regards to that coordination
idea amongst challenges.
When it comes to your neighborhood-and especially
I'm thinking of the fight against Islamic
State-is this going to be-is this an issue
of transnational governance, or is it actually
an issue of bilateral or even unilateral action
on the part of great powers or regional powers?
YADLIN: Unlike like the view from Washington,
which look at the Islamic State as the most
dangerous phenomena in the Middle East, we
still think that the most formidable threat
to the Middle East-maybe the Saudis are thinking
alike-is the Islamic Republic of Iran.
And when you look at it from an Israeli perspective,
Daesh is not a threat to Israel today.
If you put it on a scale of how many tons
of explosive our enemy can launch to Tel Aviv?
So, the Iranians, hundred of missiles with
heavy warheads.
Hezbollah, maybe thousands.
Some from Hamas, not too many.
Daesh, with all due respect, they are fighting
with Hezbollah as we speak.
And if I want to be cynical a little bit,
I wish success for both.
(Laughter.)
So Daesh is not our main concern.
It's still Iran that basically the threat
to the Middle East.
And when you look from perspective in Tel
Aviv, all the world is fighting Daesh.
Two very respected coalitions.
One led by the president of the United States,
even though he never called the 65 countries
to his headquarters to talk to them seriously,
but it's a serious coalition.
And there is another, more ugly coalition,
led by Russia, and Iran, and Syria, and Hezbollah.
And all of them fighting ISIS.
With Iran, unfortunately, we were left alone.
So we take it much more seriously.
MABRY: Your other earlier answer about Iran,
and kind of what happens in the 12 to 15 years,
and the hope, basically, of those who supported
the agreement, hoping that Iran will change-that
Iran's on a course toward change-reminded
me of kind of the lessons that we also may
have learned, I don't know, maybe too much,
from the Cold War: the U.S. facing its greatest
adversary in the Soviet Union.
There was-there was certainly containment,
and there was certainly military power involved,
but also there was waiting through a containment
of Russia while Russia crumbled.
The hope that internal dynamics will mean
that we won't have to act militarily with
regard to Iran, do you think that's silly,
not possible?
Is it possible?
Might it work?
Might Iran be on the road to change?
Might there be a way for the international
community to help that along?
YADLIN: See, the art of using your political
and military instrument is when to use them
and when not to use them.
And I think it was already mentioned in this
panel that the U.S. demonstrated the two extreme:
overreaction-two wars, $2 trillion, a decade
long, not achieving the objectives; and there
was another demonstration of inaction-the
Syrians crossed the red line, used, by the
way, if we speak about proliferation, chemical
weapon-a very dangerous chemical weapon, sarin,
2013, and nothing was done.
By the way, I don't know if you are aware,
but a month ago they used it again, even though
there was an agreement, international cooperation
between U.S. and Russia to take the chemical
weapon from Syria.
A small stock was left and used last month.
It was published in Haaretz in Israel by a
very respected reporter.
Nobody pay attention.
Most of the people didn't want to pay attention.
So, what are the consequences of using chemical
weapon?
So, going back to your question about cooperation,
what's really interesting in the Middle East
is that the interest of all the players are
(interwoven ?). And there is a new term there,
which called "friendemy."
It's not "the enemy of my enemy is my friend."
In the same time that I'm fighting my enemy,
I'm also cooperating with him.
In the same time that the U.S. and Russia
are fighting ISIS together, they have different
interests.
In the same times that Assad fight ISIS, he
is buying oil from ISIS.
And both of them fight, unfortunately, the
oppositions that is supported by the U.S.
Our enemy is Hamas.
Who is giving Hamas materials to rebuild Gaza?
Is it Saudi Arabia?
Is it Turkey?
No, it's Israel.
And we are playing with the tensions that
we want Gaza to reconstruct and to rebuild,
but we know that a high percentage is going
to build an attack tunnels for the terrorists.
So it's a complicated area.
There is a lot of convergence of interest
to Israel with countries that in the past
we didn't see as friends.
Because when I meet some of my friends from
Saudi Arabia-not officially, not on the record-the
basically-the basic argument is, look, on
Iran, we are on the same page.
Unfortunately, the Americans are here.
On Egypt, we are on the same page: we both
support Sisi.
Unfortunately, we are not sure that the Americans
are not supporting Muslim Brotherhood.
On Assad, they know that I personally think
that he is a war criminal and should be removed,
so we are on the same page.
Unfortunately, on the Palestinian-Israeli
issue, we are not on the same page.
So my Saudi friend will say, only solve the
Israeli-Palestinian issue and we will be brothers
in the open.
So there are some new opportunities here for
Israel, because when you look at the region,
we have a lot of interests that converge with
the pragmatic Sunni Arab countries which are
the majority in the Middle East.
MABRY: That is going to have to be our last
word.
Please join me in thanking the panel.
And please look at the report.
(Applause.)
I'm sorry, I'll just say one more thing before
I go.
Look at-look at the report, because it does
lay out prescriptions of how we can change
what, as Stewart said at the beginning, is
a creaky international institution system
to help us further along the road toward progress
on all these issues.
Thank you.
(Applause.)
FULLILOVE: Thank you, Marcus.
(END)